[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you just tapped into the group chat live
in the bleacher report app presented by
fanduel i'm greg ivory alongside aaron
dolan
as always we're giving away locks we're
giving away hoodies and we're giving
away nba jerseys matter of fact the
first one is going out right now aaron
you want to get in the app and hook
somebody up with a hoodie while i find a
jersey winner
let's do it guys what's up please drop
the best giffy that you have going on i
see a lot of comments coming through so
keep it up keep dropping them in
as you can see we just put out hoodies
and jersey are on the way
some people are commenting mavs and
stuff come on i really guys
i need a meme somebody dropping me so i
can give a hoodie out
erin needs a meme while aaron gets her
meme i'm gonna uh i'm gonna just give
away this jersey right now aaron i'm
gonna give away this
uh
ryan ray ryan ray actually actually i
got jd 25 23 ryan ray you're going to
get a hoodie aaron's still going to give
out her hoodie but i got jd 25 23 mavs
plus 10 and a half is a lot
uh i might be having to give away just
from a comment
all right here we go
lotto r-u-l-l-a-d-o hopefully i didn't
butcher that name love it with the jimmy
butler face you are walking away with a
hoodie thank you for commenting to me
there it is aaron gave away her hoodie
and and jd 2523
uh
he's he's giving out more takes he says
he'd win luca triple double he's just
giving out takes love that takes jd yeah
jersey
uh we'll see if he gets that trouble but
we'll actually talk about that later in
the show it is tnt tuesday meaning
fanduel is running our favorite bet
airing the three by two in both games
tonight the question is will there be
two three-pointers in the first three
minutes of the game
last week the 3x2 catch in both tnt
games the 76ers the knicks nuggets jazz
take a look
check this out there's this game plus
money there you go my team it wasn't you
know my favorite players but there's rj
barrett there draining that three
the other 30 that's the other 30
steph curry is 30 but that's the other
30 in new york
later game there you go mike conley
step back okay
okay
and then and then the joker got into
this the joker got it
with
yes they makes it look so easy uh today
we asked you on twitter which 3x2 will
cast tonight
miami heat
versus the dallas mavericks or the new
orleans pelicans taking on the phoenix
suns
and here are the results
let's see the results there they are
miami and dallas is in the lead here wow
this is surprising me
why are you surprised by that i feel
like so many shooters
they're shooters on the other side too
so
i mean we know what phoenix can do like
you know you can know
there's scooters on the other side
okay i need you guys to get in the
comments this is what i need the fans to
do i need you guys to get in the
comments and tell me which 3x2 is a lot
tonight get creative
i need gifts i call them gif errands
calls them giffies i need emojis and i
need most importantly winners only
please aaron which three by two do you
like better
so i'm rocking with the first game we go
heat mavs you have duncan robinson tyler
hero i mean they're tied with an average
of three three pointers made per game
this season also kyle lowry there on the
other side of the ball luka doncic tim
hardaway jr i mean come on guys in this
first one it is at plus money i know 63
of you are rocking with me thank you for
that i can see in the comments people
already dropping pictures of luca and
whatnot so let's go with that first game
i'm rocking with that for the three by
two but again you can bet on both of
them so take advantage
aaron is rocking with miami versus
dallas uh let me get into the comments
here let me get into the comments i got
p r h y m e t y m e that is for the
producers heat in dallas he's rocking
with the heating dodge shout out to you
you are walking away with a hoodie uh
star nova starting over with the he has
the carlton gift i have no idea what
that means but just because he's in here
commenting and contributing to the
comments in the show and it's carlton
shooting the basketball so it's kind of
relating to what we're talking about are
you starting over you're walking away
with a hoodie i got lychee 21 lichi 21
says the miami heat and the uh dallas
mavericks shout out to you
i'm
gonna call it aaron i'm gonna call it uh
you called it the people are calling it
we are riding as a family the miami heat
versus dallas three by two so uh we need
those vibes actually i need everybody
get sunsets in the comments can you guys
go look up sunsets put it in the
comments send us vibes because we are
riding this three by two erin let's move
on to the next segment we asked you in
the app how many points will luca doncha
score tonight against the heath get into
the comments and tell me how many points
luca is putting up at the end of the
game will dm one person who gets closest
and hook you up with the jersey aaron
luca is sitting at 25 and a half points
how do you feel about that number
so lucas only hit over 25 points in just
two games this season i'm rocking and
it's not fun with the under because the
heat are great at limiting players to
scoring just like the denver nuggets and
luca was only able to put up 16 points
against the nuggets last friday so i
think going against the team like the
miami heat they're going to be able to
slow him down because miami heater good
on offense but especially on defense as
well so never fun to rock with the under
but i am going to do that for his player
points prop tonight
aaron is rocking with the under aaron is
rocking with the under i'm going to give
away my pick i'm going to go with the
over but i'm just going to touch it a
little bit here i i like luca in this
matchup i'm actually actually i'll just
say that i'm going to rock with the over
i'm going to touch it later in the show
i'm giving out hoodies
i'm giving out hoodies i got hga baller
saying lucas dropping 27 tonight
dropping 27 points tonight shout out to
you h.j baller you are walking away with
the honey jt for mvp zero jt for mvp
zero says 25 he says 25 that means he's
going people are saying hammer the over
some people rock with me and some people
are saying hammer on the over
somebody said 38.
that that's what happened some people
rocks with us and then some people you
know uh
they don't rock with us but we got
roulado roulado says 27 points shout out
to you roulado you were walking away
with it everybody i said you guys are
walking away with hoodie remember after
the game we're gonna hit one of you guys
up whoever is the closest and hook you
up with the jersey but i got one
more jersey to give away right now so
let's get to this next segment we just
talked lucas points total but fanduel is
also hooking it up with the luca triple
double boost tonight aaron tell the
people what's up
yes so vandals currently boosting lucas
triple double odds from plus 460 to plus
600 now personally i know that he has
not had a triple-double so far this
season but a few people in the comments
actually a lot of people in the comments
including greg think that this could
potentially hit now i know if you're
feeling risky
you should go for it i wouldn't say put
your entire bankroll maybe five dollars
on it but i just think considering some
of his partners and crimes like you know
kristaps porzingis having to be out the
last three games to nurse his back which
is tight right now i would say that
lucas had to pick up some of the slacks
so he might go off in this game and for
that reason if you want about the triple
double i would sprinkle just a little
bit of money on that
i actually like this a lot actually
aaron and if we are odds boosting it i
will be sprinkling on this myself uh
when luca goes the maverick goes uh so
uh what i need you guys to do what i
need you guys to do uh
is get in the comments and let me know
if you guys think luca is gonna get this
triple-double i'm actually in the
comments right now i'm in the comments
right now giving away hoodies aaron um
real cuban no he says no triple doubling
half no triple double happening against
this heat
defense aaron no triple double stop
shout out to you real cuba no you were
walking away people are right
[Music]
did you hear me
uh
i got mark 243 says no he will not get
the triple double tonight don't lose
your money
i don't like the bad vibes because
because i do think lucas is getting that
but shout out to everybody
shout out to everybody that commented
you guys you guys have a fair right to
your opinion and you guys are walking
away with a hoodie uh if luca goes off
tonight he's going to have to do it
against one of the top teams in the nba
right now the miami heat are one of the
four teams with only one loss on the
record book they're currently on a four
game winning streak and
what i want to know is if you think
they'll keep the streak alive against
the mavericks get in the comments and
tell me if you think the miami heat will
beat the mavericks tonight aaron
can the heat
beat
the mavericks tonight and will they
cover the spread
so let's go through this a little bit
the mavs are 3-0 at home four and two on
the season they're only lost with some
pacers now miami's five and one against
the spread two and one against the
spread on the road so while the mavs
have won every single game at home this
season it was against the kings rockets
and spurs neither none of these teams
are or can be i should say equated to
the miami heat so i'm elaine the points
with the heat the line open minus two
it's been fed up to minus three
currently if you're looking at the money
line it's minus 152. i would suggest
delaying the points to get better value
in this one i think the heat has the
potential i'm gonna say potential to
blow them out of the water just
considering how well they've been
playing on both sides again of the ball
as i mentioned a few times already in
the show so i'm rocking with the heat in
this one
i am rocking with the heat as well aaron
you mentioned they're five and one two
and one against the spread on the road i
like my chances there you see some we
see some movement in this line we see
some movement i think there's movement
for a reason so uh i'm rocking with the
heat as well but aaron let's talk
futures the heat are currently plus 1200
to win the nba finals is that a
good value for them given what
we've seen early on
so a couple weeks back
before the start of the nba season we
were doing one of these shows and i said
that i like them at 16-1 i think they
have the pieces on offense and defense
the players just have to stay healthy
and eventually they're going to get back
victor oladipo i know that's in months
to come but still i feel like they have
a stacked roster on paper i think this
line is going to continue to move down
if the miami heat continue to play the
way they're that they are playing so if
you like this line now i would grab it
before it moves down
aaron says she'll grab it but i'll be
honest uh i don't think you guys should
touch this miami heat future uh there's
other teams that i see that can win the
championship out of the golden state
warriors but uh
that's my take uh aaron you want to pick
a commoner to win a hoodie on this one
yes let's do it
how about after you motivated
okay yeah and then get in there and then
i'll be doing
heat winning tonight
love it with the giphy the gippys stand
out to me in case you haven't noticed
guys it's the way to catch my eye
aaron loves the giphy
uh
i'll give out one sandy goat sandy goat
says yes they can they are looking very
good uh shout out to you sandy goat uh
i'll give out one more air why not i'll
give out one more why not i got uh the
comments are moving today uh
two two three says well he's not taking
it
the heat is not it oh those are bad bobs
but anyway we are uh moving on you know
we love the three by two around here but
our other favorite quick hitters are the
race to point bets i love the tinney the
race to 10 but tonight we're looking at
the race to eight i need you all to get
in the comments and tell me which team
is going to score eight points first
tonight will it be
the pelicans or the suns aaron what is
your take the pelicans are off to a
rough start this season can they get
eight on the board first
rough is an understatement they are one
in six so no i do not think they're
going to be able to get to eight points
before the defending western conference
champions but the value is not there on
the suns to score the first eight points
at -180 so there are tons of markets you
can bet on but if you are going to bet
into this i put five dollars on the
pelicans to score the first eight just
given that it's at better value it could
potentially happen it is right off the
bat maybe you know something happens in
the suns don't come out ablazing but
again be cautious in this market
yes be cautious be very cautious uh
i agree with you aaron if you're if
you're sprinkling light money sprinkling
five bucks ten bucks on it and then
throw it on the pelicans because who
knows it's the race to eight bet but i
do not like the minus 180 for the
phoenix suns so uh aaron i'm going to
follow you here let me get in the
comments though because you know the
people oh michael monio says the suns
and he gave us a sunset shout out to you
michael magno you are walking away with
a hoodie uh i also have a roulado i
think roulado won earlier
also have a sunset he's giving us good
vibes in the comments shout out to you
roulado uh lychee 21 says the suns are
starting to heat up lock it in shout out
to you uh
lychee 21 aaron i i think i also give
away a jersey here right
giving away a jersey go for it
i'm in the comments i am in the comments
and and and i'm feeling motivated and i
see motivated comments that devin booker
give shout out to you motivated you're
winning the hoodie not the jersey
because i see
i see
uh julio hernandez julio hernandez says
the sun because they are the better team
cb3 and book will go off
and get off no they will get off to a
hot start shout out to you julio you are
walking away with a jersey uh lamello
erin let's let's talk about lamela
lamello has been going over off lately
he's been going off check out this
lamello same game parlay from vlada
francois
my guy vlada there it is there it is
there it is he ate look at check this
one out there and the mountain got on
one player to have a great game
yes yes he got the points he got the
assist he got the boards and the threes
our guy bet a hundred he won 2500 he
went over 2500 actually so let's look at
some markets that lamelo can impact
aaron do you see anything you like here
so the first thing that jumps out to me
is charlotte to make the playoffs plus
128 i think that is good value i don't
see them winning their division the
miami heater obviously in that division
i don't see them winning the conference
that's you know plus 6 500. i don't see
them winning it all as well and i don't
see lamel being able to win mvp yes he
is playing well he's averaging 20.6
rebounds in 66th there's obviously other
players that are better in the league
right now so if you are looking at this
market i know the shortest line is the
plus 128 for them to make the playoffs
but i think out of all the options on
the board that's the one i would go with
all right aaron
shout out
to your pick because i'm going to follow
you with that pick uh i do not see
lamella winning mvp uh i don't think
they'll win the division
don't think they'll win the conference
and i don't think they'll win the finals
so the only one that makes sense is the
plus 128 bet for the charlotte hornets
to make the playoffs i do see them
having a uh having the potential to make
the playoffs this season they all they
have gotten off to a hot start uh let me
hop into these comments though and let
me hop into these comments giving away
hoodies uh
gquinn24 says i think charlotte's making
the playoffs is definitely a lock shout
out to you you're welcome away with it
those are good vibes uh
i got roulado is back in the comments
shouting out lamelo shout out to you
rolando you already have one eve
appreciate you for
uh
commenting again uh i got kxp says
absolutely not playoffs yes but
definitely not a title i agree with you
i don't see them winning the title
appreciate all the comments man
appreciate all the comments everybody
that i mentioned you guys are walking
away with a hoodie aaron
let's get to the last segment this week
and for the rest of the season we're
doing something very special i'm
building my same game parlay as usual
but now you're going to have a chance to
ride with me i need all of you to get in
the comments and tell me what do you
think of my parlay which legs or locks
which legs is ruining the parlay and i'm
going to need you to grade my parlay
from an a to f there's no f's here give
me a's yeah i'll leave it as that i'm
giving out a jersey to my favorite take
are you guys ready aaron are you ready
yes let's do it
all right let's get right into it let's
get right into it uh
let's get into it i got kyle lowry here
and i had to think about it i think
where i wanted to start with it let's
start off with kyle we got kyle lowry 15
plus points lock it in aaron show me
some love do you like this
well he's averaging eight points per
game so far this season so he is going
to have to go off tonight but again the
heat look good so there is always a
potential for him to do that
okay okay we got tim hardaway 15 plus
points aaron
come on and he's like
down the three
okay
thank you thank you all right here we go
aaron we've been talking about luca but
i think luca's gonna have a great game
follow me here we got luca 25 plus
points we got lucas six plus rebounds
and we got luca eight plus assists i
think he's gonna have a triple-double we
talked about it earlier in the show uh
i'm just gonna
sprinkle that on to my same game parlay
right here or do you like that
so i know that i had said the under for
lucas points props so hopefully that if
if he does go over this and he's able to
hit all of these then you have the odds
boost cash we have your same game parlay
hopefully cash so i think it's all
around good
good same game parliament okay okay i am
feeling the vibes i'm feeling i need
sunsets in the comments please need
sunsets in the comments let's put the
odds up let's put the odds up
let's put the odds up uh there are the
odds you guys see it 100 win eight eight
thirty six you know eight thirty steps
get you some money man get y'all some
money
um aaron before i get into the comments
what are you grading mark parley
so i'm gonna grade your parlay a b only
because i was going under for luca but
if he does go off again the odds boost
will catch the same game prolay will
have a better chance to cash also i'm
really banking on kyle lowry to have a
great game for the same game parlay to
cash
gonna need him to step up okay
the bb but it beats hillary b is good
baseball b's b
shout out to you ross garza you're
walking away with the hoodie hga baller
is with you aaron giving me a b shout
out to you hgh hga bowler you were
walking away
drew 84 also gave me a plus shout out to
you hey i'm feeling the love i'm feeling
the love uh
aaron i think it's time to uh
get on up out of here uh yeah thank you
guys for tapping into the group chat
presented by fanduel remember what you
learned today the miami versus dallas
3x2 is a lot luca doncic is going off
the heat futures are looking good early
and get on fanduel to tame to tell my
same game parlay we'll be back next week
giving out more hoodies more jerseys
more locks if you want a hoodie today we
will dm you get on fanduel ride with us
on social follow us on social follow me
follow aaron follow br betting alongside
aaron dolan i'm greg ivory we are
leaving the group chat peace
[Music]
you